écoutez monsieur b que oui a priori la
26e 2 sera plus efficace que la 25e et
encore une fois à priori sera plus
protectrice par rapport aux nouveaux
variants qui nous vient de
jeu tchèque parce que c'est pas
l'andalousie c'est pas le népal s'est
pas les pyrénées c'est pas les pays de
la loire le vercors voilà et apparemment
qui est très agressif
[Musique]
vous ne voyez plus de la gauche ah oui
ça c'est embêtant mais apparemment ce
serait les effets secondaires de la 14e
dose ça ouais vous n'êtes pas le seul et
bonne nouvelle pour vous avec la 26e
doses oui ça pourrait guérir ce petit
bourg ou alors c'est quitte ou double au
niveau des chercheurs c'est à dire que
soit vous recouvrait entièrement la vue
donc super nouvelle soit vous la perdez
entièrement voilà donc après c'est la
recherche un monsieur b cause et on
cherche on cherche on trouve au cherche
on trouve pas être parfois on trouve
qu'on n'est pas venu chercher mais on le
prend quand même
[Musique]
et
puis on n'a pas la science infuse on
n'est pas des tisanes c'est de l'humour
médical monsieur bigot sais pas si vous
comprenez pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on n'est pas des pigeons monsieur b qu
on n'est pas des pigeons